[Music]
focus right here
[Applause]
heal me
always
you're me
darling
[Music]
food at home a house cleaned
and discretion above all else
boys and their toys at least we know
they're getting work done
[Music]
welcome to the victory project we're all
here because we believe in the mission
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
that's right
what do you think
they're really doing out there
what do you mean
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
[Music]
where it's safe
do you even know what the victory
project actually is have you ever asked
do you
please
what's actually happening stopping alice
what if this place
no
jack
it's okay
i'm curious to hear where she's going
with this
i need you to listen to me
[Music]
you're lying about everything
we are not going backwards we're pushing
forward
everyone is acting like i'm crazy
and i'm not crazy
[Music]
our life together
we could lose this
i don't trust it
and i don't want to be here anymore
[Music]
[Music]
you